alors en allemagne comme en france il y
à des tensions entre ceux qui ont plutôt
proche des agriculteurs et ceux qui sont
plutôt proche des écolos du lobby
agricole qui a gagné je voudrais
féliciter nicolas hulot pour sa ténacité
je pense que c'est une une bonne
direction d'avoir donné une échéance
parce qu'il faut avoir conscience que la
décision européenne ne donne pas
d'échéance autorise pour 5 ans mais on
ne sait pas ce qui se passe au bout de
cinq ans donc avoir marqué une volonté
d'accélérer la recherche et la
révolution interne à la même position
sur cette question centrale
je pense que sur ces sujets beaucoup
plus large des pesticides
il va falloir travailler comme pour la
coop et le réchauffement climatique sur
l'agression de consensus scientifique on
peut pas douter de la science en
constructif c'est un peu ce que ça fait